how do you think this stuff got in this
yard see that's the whole thing we found
it in different areas of the yard so the
last time it was right over here
previously it was found over in these
areas
so why aren't police investigating an
attempted dog poisoning in a valley
neighborhood thanks for joining us at
six i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis a dog owner says someone threw
poisonous kibble in his yard when he
called for help officers said they
couldn't do much the 8 news now i-team's
david charns here with that story and
why david brian denise we hear about
these dog poisoning cases from time to
time most recently in the west part of
the valley in the lakes neighborhood
tonight we focus on henderson a dog
owner says someone tried to kill his
pets and he's upset with what police and
animal control told him
so you found the kibble in this area
correct it would be very difficult for
him to throw from the street
throw it from back there or even throw
it from over there steve palero shows us
where he found kibble laced with
antifreeze in his backyard that's when
we contacted the police department and
they had sent us over to animal control
it's not the first time this long time
henderson dog owner says he's had
trouble he says his first dog got sick
and died several years ago then late
last year dylan now recovered got sick
too palero has since added mercy to the
pack and now when they come out it's
like one of us is always with them we
can only bring them out on it on a leash
and that takes away a lot of enjoyment
for them as well as us palero found the
tainted pieces of food in late march he
sent them out to get tested the results
positive for poison he then called
police we couldn't understand we said
well can you guys at least come out and
do a report you know maybe that could
make some people aware
and their results of that phone call was
well we're going to send you over to
animal control
animal control followed up but without
any video or eyewitnesses a city
spokesperson says there wasn't anything
for officers to investigate palero puts
it this way well we don't can't really
do anything if you can catch who it is
on tape
and let us know who it is we'll send a
citation to them
i mean
send a citation to somebody that's
trying to kill things there were cameras
before now there's more in case this
person strikes again
with an inviting backyard to entertain
friends and their children palero fears
the worst with the person who did this
on the loose you know if it can kill a
50-60 pound dog
what about a 20 pound kid
we asked henderson police and animal
control just how many dog poisonings
there have been in the city but they
tell us they actually don't track that
we asked the same question to metro
police and a spokesperson tells us there
are no known poisonings so far this year
but that three cases from the lakes
remain unsolved tonight i'm david charns
live local now